use all three equations I'm going to
start by trying to eliminate one of the
variables we're gonna pick Z because it
looks like that's going to be the
easiest to eliminate but you could you
know start with eliminating Y's or X's
but let's go ahead and eliminate the Z's
first and we'll do that by combining the
first and the second equation if we add
those together we get 3x minus y the Z's
are going to cancel equals 1 okay now we
want to use all three equations we use
use the first two we want to use the
third one so let's go ahead and combine
it with the second one you can combine
it with the first or the second but you
want to use that third equation so we
use all three what I'm going to do here
is I'm going to multiply this middle
equation times two so that's going to
give us 4x minus 6y plus 2z equals
negative 2 the third equation I'm just
going to bring down and we're going to
add these two together so if we do that
we get 9x minus 7y equals negative 5 ok
now we're down to two equations with two
variables just X's and Y's so let's
multiply this equation by negative 7 so
we get a positive 7y we can add it to
this equation and eliminate the Y's so
if we do that we get 21 X ok negative 21
x plus 7y equals negative 7 we're going
to add those together we get negative
12x the Y's cancel we get negative 12
divided by negative 12x equals 1 so we
went from three equations with three
variables down to two equations with two
variables down to one equation with one
variable now we're going to work our way
backwards okay so we're going to put
this into one of the equations that has
just two variables let's put it into
this one over here so 3 times 1 minus y
equals 1 we put in 1 for X so subtract 3
from both sides that gives you negative
2 divided by negative 1 y equals 2 so
now we know what X and y are let's go
ahead and put it back into one of the
original equations to solve for Z so
we'll just do this top one so we have 1
plus y is 2 so it
two times two is four minus Z equals two
that's five minus Z equals 2 subtract 5
that equals negative 3 divided by
negative 1 is Z equals 3 so now we have
XY and Z and we're going to write this
as a triple XYZ alphabetical order 1 2 3
X Y Z okay so you just write it as a
trip